We are Girls5eva!
Why Girls5eva?
Because we’re gonna be famous 5eva!
They were a thing for a second
back around ’99, 2000.
I was a baby in ’99,
but I like it.
It’s old school.
Makes me think of my mom’s boobies.
Oh, God.
Girls5eva booked a gig.
Reunion!
I don’t know if we should do this.
Don’t say that!
[clap]
Was that good?
I’ve tried out for the Housewives like eight times.
Cool.
Does Wickie know about this?
Let’s go, ladies.
I have places to be.
On the runway to the runway.
Fashion life.
What the hell are you doing?
Take that scarf off!
You want to get sucked into an engine?
Sorry, sir!
We don’t need Larry anymore.
Try to sound horny!
The messages in our songs are bad!
♪  Jail bait,  ♪
♪ great at sex, ♪
♪ but it’s our first time. ♪
I’m gonna write us a hit.
An anthem to things that
aren’t perfect but are still great.
That’s like us.
We’re gonna have the biggest
comeback in pop music history.
Everybody sing from your diaphragm.
Okay, which one?
Oh my God!
Remember these ladies?
Girls5eva!
I just did mandatory sensitivity training.
See?  I air honk now.
Growing.
Learning.
Ally.
Four grown ladies trying to be pop stars again.
Strap in!
♪ Girls5eva. ♪
Too early.
[scream]
That was Sprite.